hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd skin care nerd and owner of really
long super bleached hair that's almost completely
grown out after two years i get asked a lot about
whether or not i recommend silk for skin and hair
and so today i'm going to be talking about some of
the claims you might have heard about silk and
whether or not they make sense this video is
sponsored by lilysilk who make a lot of the silk
products i'm going to be showing in this video
their silk products are relatively reasonably
priced if you like nerding out about the science
behind beauty products subscribe and click the
nerdification bell so you don't miss any videos
let's start with hair because that's where i see
the biggest difference first up i'm going to tell
you straight there are no published peer-reviewed
direct clinical trials on using silk for improving
your skin or hair it's really annoying but
this is the case with a lot of beauty stuff
research is expensive and a lot of peer-reviewed
research is funded by the government it's really
hard for the government to justify spending
money to help you get smoother hair or nicer skin
when it could be spending this money on like
cancer research but we do know that silk is really
slippery it has a lower coefficient of friction
than a lot of other pillowcase materials like
linen and cotton and we know that mechanical wear
and tear is one of the main causes of hair damage
this includes combing brushing hair ties and
even hair strands sliding past each other so
given that we sleep for about a third of our lives
and we're smooshing our hair into the pillowcase
it makes sense that there's a lot of damage
happening there and using a less frictiony
pillowcase might help silk also doesn't absorb as
much water as cotton or linen and so if your hair
is quite porous and prone to losing moisture then
using a less absorbent pillow case might also help
keep it more moisturized my first silk pillow
case was from silk and i first started using it
before i dyed my hair and i didn't see much of
a difference and i think the reason for that is
because as my hairdresser put it my hair is strong
as sh** but after double bleaching it my hair got
really fragile and porous it started drying out
really easily and i saw a massive difference
when i slept on a silk pillowcase versus my usual
cotton ones when i woke up after sleeping on the
silk one it felt like my hair was normal but on
the cotton one it felt like all the conditioner
had worn off my hair and it was catching
on itself and it felt crunchy and dried out
and duller and frizzy the biggest difference
is when i'm lazy and i don't dry out my hair
properly before i go to sleep this is really bad
because when your hair's wet the cuticle stands
up and these are like scales and so they stick up
more and so they're more likely to bash into each
other and cause lots of damage so don't do this
but with cotton when i go to sleep with wet or
even slightly damp hair when i wake up it's really
knotted and crunchy but with silk it's a lot more
manageable lily silk have a huge range of pillow
cases i've been trying out the 19 momme ones which
are about 30 us dollars each this is way cheaper
than a lot of the other ones on the market which
is really good because then you can buy a few
and rotate them one of the big worries i had
about silk was with washing but it turns out it's
actually not that hard to look after it ideally
you'd hand wash them or dry clean them but i've
actually been washing them in my regular laundry
i turned them inside out put them in a delicates
bag and then put them on a delicate spin cycle
at a low temperature with liquid detergent and my
older silk pillow case is about three years old
and is still going strong i also hang them on the
line away from direct sun apart from pillowcases
there are a few other options for keeping your
hair nice with silk so if you have long hair
like me a lot of your hair might hang off the
pillow and it's usually the ends that are the
most damaged and most prone to getting more damage
if you don't tie up your hair then your hair can
get caught between your body and the sheets and
get really smushed there so you can use silk
sheets but they are pretty expensive so much more
budget-friendly option is to use the silk bonnet
so you can gather up your hair and put it inside
this and so it keeps it all together and safe
now with silk and skin it's a similar story
again silk has less friction and it doesn't
absorb as much water and so it can help with some
skin issues you might have heard that silk pillow
cases can prevent wrinkles because of the low
friction it means that your skin gets tugged less
i'm not super convinced by this reasoning there
are things called sleep wrinkles but these are
mostly caused by your sleeping position if you
sleep on your side or your stomach then your
face gets smushed and creased and over time this
repeated creasing can lead to an etched in wrinkle
these sleep lines are vertical and they don't
quite match with your muscle movements which is
where most of your wrinkles come from but sleep
wrinkles mostly come from the weight of your head
which is pretty darn heavy compared to the weight
of your head the impact of the friction from your
pillowcase is really tiny if you're worried
about sleep lines i recommend switching to
sleeping on your back rather than changing the
material of your pillowcase changing your sleep
position can be difficult and it can impact other
areas of your health so it might not be worth it
depending on your individual situation but if you
are interested there are special pillows designed
for helping you sleep on your back but one skin
benefit i have found with using a silk pillowcase
is that i get less awkward creases on my skin
when i wake up you know how sometimes your pillow
imprints itself on your skin and you've got like a
crease and you try to put makeup over it and it's
like a bit awkward and it takes a little while
to fade and i'm the sort of person who tries to
sleep as long as possible so there's a relatively
short amount of time between me getting out of bed
and seeing people i noticed that i got a lot less
of these when i started using silk pillowcases
another good thing about silk is that
it doesn't absorb as much moisture as
something like cotton and so when i'm
using a silk pillow case i find that i
wake up with my skin a lot more hydrated
and plump and smooth it also doesn't soak
up as much of your products as cotton and
so your skincare products go less to waste
and theoretically that means it's feeding
bacteria a bit less and so your pillowcase
will get gross slower you should be washing
your pillowcases regularly to prevent breakouts
you might have heard some people
say that silk has amino acids which
can absorb through your skin and feed it
this is a myth silk does have amino acids
but they're bound up into protein chains
that are too big to go through your skin
this is a good thing because it means it stays
in the pillowcase and so your pillowcase doesn't
slowly get absorbed into your skin and at the
end of the day you still have a pillowcase
another good use of silk that i found is with
face masks i don't know about the rest of you
but i've been having massive issues with maskne
this is breakouts that come on your face because
you've been wearing a face mask i've been getting
really angry irritated red spots in places where i
usually don't get breakouts and my chin has been a
bit of a disaster i've done a video before talking
about dermatologist advice for avoiding maskne
the main reasons that you get these breakouts is
because the mask is rubbing against your skin and
that makes it really irritated you also have a ton
of moisture trapped under there from your breath
and from your sweat and this is the perfect storm
for your skin barrier to get compromised and so it
gets more irritated it gets more leaky and so that
means breakouts silk is one of your best bets for
dealing with the friction because it's so slippery
i've been trying out a range of different silk
face masks this one is from an australian silk
clothing brand called banded together it
has these really nice adjustable ear loops
and it's got two layers of silk my original silk
pillowcase company is also making face masks this
is their black marble pattern lilysilk also made
these very thin two layer rayon silk face masks
this is what i've been using under a surgical
face mask or a normal cloth face mask to try to
reduce some of that friction it fits really
nicely under a standard surgical face mask and so
this just goes underneath and it prevents some
of that chafing i've found that this is really
helping but one of the main problems is when i
have this under my face it's like an extra layer
and it gets a little bit harder to breathe
through so inhaling through my nose takes a
bit more effort but inhaling through my mouth is
fine so yeah when i'm sitting on public transport
i have this underneath when i get out and start
walking i take this off and just use the face mask
on its own so that way i cut down on my overall
friction plus getting rid of this in the middle
means that some of the moisture gets taken away as
well i haven't been using these for that long but
i found that it's already cut down a lot of that
irritation and friction if your body skin is quite
sensitive and easily irritated then you might find
that wearing silk clothing helps as well because
it's so slippery lilysilk have a big range of silk
clothing as well so this shirt is from lilysilk
so those are the benefits of silk there are some
drawbacks as well firstly silk isn't vegan it's
produced by silkworms and the silkworms
are killed during the production process
so if you're vegan you probably want to avoid silk
silk is also one of the more expensive fabrics
lilysilk do have some really affordable options
like the 19 momme pillow cases but other fabrics
are usually going to be cheaper there are some
satin fabrics that have similar benefits to silk
the satin refers to how the fabrics woven
together so that they're smoother and less
frictiony and more silk-like but they tend to
have other drawbacks so for a long time i was
quite hesitant about using silk pillow cases
because one of my friends in high school used
to have satin pillowcases and every time i slept
over my hair would go really flat and staticky and
my head would get really hot and sweaty later
on i realized that this was because they were
polyester satin i haven't had any of these
issues with the silk pillow cases i've tried
if you do want to try a satin fabric i'd
recommend sateen this is cotton based so
it shouldn't have these heat or static problems
but it will still absorb more moisture than silk
another disadvantage of silk is that you do need
to iron it which is more important for clothing
than for pillowcases i've kind of structured my
whole wardrobe so i don't have to iron things
but silk does need ironing but it does also
feel really smooth and it's really hard to
stop touching myself so that's all from me about
silk if you have any recommendations for fabric
for pillowcases or silk brands that are worth
trying leave them in the comments as usual like
it if you like subscribe follow me on instagram
and check out my blog for more beauty science
thank you again to lilysilk for sponsoring
this video and i'll see you next time